it is April 1st 2023 and I'm going to
resist the urge to pull any April Fool's
jokes on you instead we're just going to
do the regular standard update video in
which I'll tell you about what we've got
coming up in April and what you might
have missed in the month of March I
always like to begin by talking about
three big things and I actually do have
three pretty significant things on the
horizon or already you could say in the
bag so big thing number one probably the
biggest of them all I am going to be
offering some summer classes online and
I'm going to be putting out some videos
about these and stuff in social media in
the coming weeks I'll be teaching about
Descartes and Aristotle and Plato and
the philosophy of friendship so stay
tuned for that big thing number number
two I have finally gotten into the
groove and started publishing more
frequently in medium which I plan to use
as one of my main platforms for written
works short public philosophy stuff and
big thing number three is that I have
restarted the ideas that matter uh
conversations about important topics and
philosophy and other stuff with an
interview with a good friend and
colleague Massimo pigliucci about
ciceronian eclecticism and I plan to be
continuing quite a few more of these in
the coming months and perhaps for years
to come so those are the three big
things let's talk now about March March
as usual was quite a busy month and a
lot of online events some of them hosted
on my platform some on others so
actually let me start talking about one
that I did with somebody else I went on
the chatting with knots with Jimmy nuts
and we talked about speculative fiction
the conversation went so well that we're
going to do another one down the line
after he's finished with the Earthsea
series by Ursula Kayla green
we talked about some general stuff for
about two hours and we're going to focus
in on Earth see next so that'll be
coming up I also did my worlds of
speculative fiction this month we
focused on Kim Stanley Robinson's Mars
Trilogy looking at the first two books
in that and it was uh quite quite good
those are some excellent works I did my
usual AMA and we did another
self-directed study providing advice
this time about how to study hegelian
philosophy or specifically hegel's
philosophy we had a couple wisdom for
Life shows that aired that you can watch
I also as I mentioned did the ideas that
matter interview with Massimo pigliucci
and we had a really great conversation
about close to 90 minutes about all
sorts of things centering on ciceronian
eclecticism so that remains like
thinking about ancient philosophy modern
times how it is that we appropriate
these sorts of things and uh just
recently my uh interview with radio
Uninvited about the you know nature of
doing philosophy and a little bit of my
back story as well aired
um
I've had you know academic classes on
going at Marquette University where I'm
teaching a class specifically on anger
and Justice and two classes at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design and intro to
Humanities and a philosophy mindfulness
in life which is oriented around
philosophies as ways of life and you
know we've been exploring mostly
um stoicism and cynicism this month and
we're getting close to wrapping up with
those I've also been doing a lot of work
with clients doing philosophical
counseling and tutorials and uh you know
some some Consulting work as well I did
write as I mentioned a number of medium
posts one of them was actually a Roundup
of my various writings on stoicism in
medium at this point I've got about 54
articles so you could check that out I
also did a few things about heavy metal
classic metal class number 15
one about my first metal album which was
Kiss Destroyer and then a lot of stuff
about stoicism two things on Seneca and
anger management some more Epictetus and
caridian commentary stuff
stoic fortitude failure and failing and
failures there's two posts on that and
then I did some other things one about
Tolkien videos uh sort of a Roundup of
the videos that I did in speculative
fiction studies a while back on his on
fairy tales I did one recently on the
Paradox of care something I'm going to
expand out into eventually like an
entire book and a few other things
having to do with memories of uh time
and some playing around with chat GPT so
a lot of stuff on the writing front in
medium which I'm happy about because I
do want to work there quite a bit more I
did also shoot a lot of videos in
addition to all of these event videos
you know for worlds of speculative
fiction or the AMA or things like that
we also did some core concept videos for
my classes seneca's on anger got into
book two I'm going to be doing book
three later on
um the cynic Epistles that are
attributed to Kratos not actually by
karate taste most likely but certainly
attributed to him and
um recently I've started doing some on
Marcus aurelius's meditations that I
know people have been asking for and
looking forward to for quite a while I
also got to three Sadler's stories
videos and you know those are always fun
to record and of course we had the ideas
that matter video as well uh podcast
wise I did in fact release quite a few
podcast episodes we finished up the the
series on Aquinas and his discussions of
anger and then we jumped into Aristotle
book Seven went through all of those and
by the way
I now have not just video lectures but
podcast episodes on every single topic
in the nick of McCain ethics which is
you know quite a lot
and then we got into Blaze Pascal I I've
been you know redoing some some uh video
work and turning them into podcasts
about his passes and uh we'll probably
continue on with with those so pretty
busy month in in March a lot going on
and uh oh I should mention too that we
had our understanding anger 2.0 class we
focused on Plato that was a lot of fun
um so those are all the things that we
did in March right so coming up in April
uh I'm releasing this on the first in
what's my morning and shortly after this
if you want to you've got the
opportunity to jump in on a conversation
that I've been invited to on somebody
else's platform acid Horizon is bringing
me in as a guest again to talk about
ancient philosophy and views on the
emotion of anger something I'm a
specialist in and should be a good
conversation that will be happening at
noon Central time today the first of
April
and you can find links to everything
Below in the video description so you
can always find where to go for these on
the eighth we will have at noon Central
time we'll have my usual AMA that is ask
me anything session you can pop in and
get answers not just about philosophy
but other things as well my views on
politics uh heavy metal things that I've
talked about in other videos that you're
curious about
also on the eighth uh following the AMA
for patreon supporters we will have a
philosophy chat which is a much more
intimate video conferencing session
where people can you know get some more
intensive discussion or q a about things
that they're interested in following
that on the ninth we will be having uh
the next Sadler's storytelling video uh
which is a you know sort of a live event
is basically just me sitting there
reading one of my favorite short stories
this time it's one of my favorite short
stories by Jorge Louis Borges the
lottery at Babylon a short piece that
I've been thinking about basically since
I read it as an undergraduate back in
the early 90s on the 12th at 5 00 PM
we'll have our public monthly uh Hegel q
a and discussion session you can pop in
and get answers about Hegel who's rather
confusing about German idealism about
philosophy more generally that's a video
conferencing session on the 15th at noon
Central time we'll be having
understanding anger 2.0 class session
three now that if you want to do that
you've got to enroll in the free class
and the reason I owe Academy and then
you get the zoom link and you can
participate we're going to be discussing
anger in Plato's dialogues take two a
more systematic approach looking at it
in the Republic the phaedris and in the
Timaya so obviously we're focusing on
the tripartite soul and the faculty of
thumos right
then on the 16th at 11 A.M and it's 11
A.M so that I can afterwards go out and
visit with some cats and a cat shelter
we will be having the next self-directed
study advice video premiere this time
around because you know I've been doing
some videos on it and people are
interested in it cynic philosophy which
presents a particular challenge given
that we don't have any of the original
texts from the first several generations
of the cynics how do you study this sort
of thing I'll be giving you some advice
about that and you can join in ask
questions and see what it is that I have
to say whether it's any help or not
the next weekend and I'm not quite sure
when it's going to be scheduled but I
will be reading a paper here in uh was
in Wisconsin
specifically at Marquette University
which is hosting the Wisconsin
philosophical association meeting it'll
either be on the 22nd or the 23rd I will
be asking and answering the question
what is public philosophy so I made a
proposal they accepted it now I'm in the
position of having to write the paper
and present it I'm going to try to
record that so obviously a lot of people
aren't going to be may be able to make
it here we'll see what they're cool with
as far as recording as far as that goes
and then finally on the 29th we will
have our worlds of speculative fiction
session at noon Central Time uh two
parts we have a video premiere where
we'll be doing the uh the third book in
the Mars series by Kim Stanley Robinson
blue Mars might bring in some short
stories from the Martians as well and
then following the video premiere and
live chat we always have a video
conferencing to follow up and have some
additional discussion so that should be
a lot of fun I'm going to be doing a lot
of writing this month I'm going to be
you know continuing on with my classes
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
finishes in April but grades are due I
think a little bit after that Marquette
goes on I think for another two weeks or
so and then it's on to summer classes
after that
as far as video work goes for this
coming month I've got to get back into
shooting the half hour Hegel videos
we're so close to the end that I really
want to get this thing finished wrapped
up well so I'll try to get at least two
or three videos done this month I also
have a lot of book reviews to do that
I've been sitting on for a while so
we'll be prioritizing that but we'll be
doing some more of these ideas that
matter uh you know conversation
interview videos about interesting
topics I've got a few guests already
lined up for these I'll be doing some
more Sadler's stories videos and then
what else you know core concept videos
these are mostly things that I'm
teaching right now so you know more
Marcus Aurelius more Seneca in this case
we're going to be looking at on the
shortness of life so you should see some
of those coming out in the the following
weeks after we get through some Marcus
Aurelius and then we'll see where we go
after that you know I'm going to be
shooting some stuff on John Cassie and
anger whether it gets released in April
or in May is yet to be seen I've still
got more on seneca's on anger to shoot
as well so lots of core concept videos
and you know you might see some other
one-off things pop up evil Sadler could
raise his foolish head and you know
spout his nonsense who knows you know
you never know when that guy's gonna pop
out there and there'll be announcements
about the online classes and stuff like
that as well
uh podcast so you know we're releasing
these episodes on pascals ponce's uh
after that it's Aristotle's rhetoric
book two the discussions of anger and
then we'll probably start doing some
stuff on locktancius the great early
Christian philosopher and his own book
about the anger of God that I did videos
on back in I want to say the fall and
now we're turning them into podcast
episodes so a lot of stuff coming up
this month I'll leave you with uh
something that's not really philosophy
related but you might find you know
interesting or endearing so you heard me
mention just a little bit earlier that
um on my Sundays I'm
often going to this cat shelter there's
a place here in Milwaukee actually in a
building that I used to work in called
Almost Home cat shelter and
um
I'm uh going in with no intent to adopt
any new animals just to hang out with
them play you know give attention
affection and stuff like that and I go
to what the what's called their open
houses when you can go in they have
hours on on Sundays and you know I've
gotten kind of attached to these these
two feline leukemia positive cats both
are quite young Earnest and Maxine
Ernest is a little roughhauser Maxine is
rather shy but they're both really quite
sweet and I'll put a link below if you
want to contribute to to them you know
they're a great organization I think
once the school year is over I'm
actually going to go and start
volunteering there to you know do some
of the work that's needed with with
these uh rescue animals and so that's
you know good place to end
um got a new thing that I'm doing on on
Sundays started doing that back in March
and so far I've been there three times
and it's a really great place good
people and wonderful little animals so
hope you have a great month ahead in
April
um not like I said you might have been
listening to this waiting where is the
April Fool's joke gonna be the joke is
that there is no joke so you have fun
and maybe you can join me for the acid
Horizon thing later today if not I'm
sure you'll see it on their video
channel later on and I will see you at
some of these online events or perhaps
even face to face here in Milwaukee and
uh have a great month